l'entrée en sixième c'est historique une
femme à la tête d'une assemblée
exécutive en alsace brigitte klinkert a
été élu président du conseil
départemental du haut-rhin ce matin
remplacement d'eric straumann contraint
à la démission pour respecter le non
cumul des mandats une élection à
l'unanimité à laquelle assistaient
géraldine dre hier tout à leur bonjour
géraldine élections toutefois sans
surprise c'est vrai caroline élection
historique et en même temps élections
fluide elle a sonné comme une évidence
il faut dire qu'il n'y avait qu'une
seule candidate à la succession d'eric
straumann et brigitte klinkert a été élu
à l'unanimité mois un bulletin blanc que
l'on vive deviennent en fait être sa
propre voie un signe d'humilité
d'élégance de la part de cette femme qui
fait office de pionnière en politique en
alsace c'est elle qui pousse les portes
pour les femmes elle fut élue première
conseillère départementale ici à colmar
en 94 et maintenant eh bien elle préside
cette assemblée l'élection de brigitte
klinkert a été saluée comme une avancée
démocratique par les conseillères
départementale ici présentes
je vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
lara million suivi de bain du doyen de
cette assemblée c'est un homme il
s'appelle michel habig c'est vrai que
les choses bougent c'est le premier
mandat où il y à parité on s'est très
bien entendu entre hommes et femmes
on a une vraie complémentarité parce que
ce soit une femme vous pensez que ça va
changer quelque chose
je pense un pouilly puisqu'une femme
peut-être à une approche différente d'un
homme et peut être aussi dans les
négociations que ça peut être un atout
c'est à dire peut-être une diplomatie
différentes
voilà une hypothèse caroline qu'il
faudra peut-être vérifier dans les
prochains mois faut dire que brigitte
klinkert arrive en cours de mandature ce
qui n'est pas toujours facile en
politique mais ils sont tous unanimes
ici il estime que son élection est une
suite logique de son parcours politique
et qu'elle aura la capacité de s'imposer
parce qu'elle a le caractère qui est
fait pour la france caroline je vous
rappel compte désormais onze femmes
présidentes de conseils départementaux
merci pour ces précisions